[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I tried for the most provocative
title that I could come up with for my
for my talk here who came because the
title was kind of fun that's it all
right who came because they were cool
they're satisfying some requirement of
going to enough of these none okay one
of these days I'm going to come up with
a stand-up comedy act for analytics
because I think that's maybe the thing
I'm at I'm like I I think I'm a funny
person so maybe maybe and I'm a crappy
data scientist so like maybe that's what
I'll be good at so we all have to find
our competitive comparative advantage
right I mean we have to figure out what
we're good at relative to everybody else
and I can almost guarantee that all of
you are better coders than I am my my
background is a little a little weird to
be in this space and I think it's it's
it's given me a perspective that I hope
is useful to you in the next 30 or 40
minutes of talking who leads the data
science team a couple of you all right
and how about individual contributors
the rest and then the remainder of you
do what what do you do looking for work
who exactly is looking for employment
okay all right so feel free to follow me
if you want the native that my company's
name is data iku I know it's tough to
spell sometimes people think it's
Japanese it's not necessarily Japanese
we actually started in France and we've
moved the corporate headquarters to the
US typically we we spell it data data IQ
as one word and it's the combination of
haiku for structure and data as obvious
okay I'll do a little advertisement at
the very very end we can cut it off if
we want but let's get to the meat of the
talk here so I think what's kind of
important is to is to get a little bit
of
ground on on who I am and how I got here
and why you're listening to me so that
was me most of my life alright I was
like the I'm a weird I'm a weird guy my
dad was a Salesman my mom was a
schoolteacher I thought I wanted to be a
you know athlete for the longest time
and then I decided now I'm going to be a
teacher and so a professor so I went and
I went a lot of school and I thought I
wanted to be a college professor and I
got out and I did that and it was a
tremendous amount of fun and so you know
the the athlete sort of turned into like
the kojiki I was joked at the Kendall
thing so I have a I have a very good
friend that has sort of coined this
concept of being underestimated right
and it's good to be underestimated
sometimes they can give you a chip put a
chip on your shoulder but at the same
time it's maybe not a bad idea for
people to believe that your one thing
and then you kill them with competence
in the other direction right so so
anyway that that's sort of my transition
in life and I've moved around a little
bit and off to where I'm not exactly
sure where I if I wear glasses or not
anymore I can't tell but if you tell
yourself long long enough that you're
something you'll start to believe it and
so for a while I believed that I wanted
to be a data scientist professor and
then I moved into the data science space
and then I now move into like the the
talking about data science and
organizing data science and and thinking
about how data science production works
and so we all need to sort of examine
who we are and how we fit in to
analytics I tweeted out earlier today
yes that's a shameless plug for
economics which is my twitter handle
that if you're not making software using
software or selling software in a couple
years you're going to be in trouble
right and we're all in the software
business so we're in good shape
there's a lot of big companies out there
and I do get to deal with a lot of them
that are figuring that out and employees
and those companies are figuring it out
we're going to get there it's just
taking time I did a great interview this
morning with a podcast with Jeff Chou
just on the room is he so Jeff it works
at Heroku and we were talking about how
how different companies where different
companies are and their maturity towards
towards digital transformation and
everybody's at a different stage and
just because we don't work at a so a lot
of us probably work at tech companies
full and we're full stack data
scientists most the world's not that way
all right
we kind of forget that the rest of the
world is catching up especially in the
valley right like note we we have no
perspective of how far back a lot of the
rest of the world happens to be so my
algal years so after I taught I jumped
to a machine learning company actually
in the valley and I spent a year there
if any of you you know following jump on
LinkedIn you'll see quickly where I was
and you probably all know it a great
year I enjoyed it I learned a tremendous
amount that was my second stand in
algorithms and so I work for the SAS
Institute for a long time and the SAS
Institute has of course made SAS
software for many years anybody actually
use SAS in here one hey that's pretty
good
so so SAS is great software you know I
always sort of tell the story that you
know SAS suffers from an image problem
right like imagine if this Mac wasn't
pretty and it was like super super ugly
right it just filled with a lot of good
stuff
all right SAS sort of got you know it's
really good software it just has a
legacy issue right that it has a hard
time getting getting past anyway I
worked in advanced analytics R&D in the
algo side then I worked for a machine
learning company in the algo side and I
learned something that's I never I will
never let go and that's that algos are
great but they don't solve the problem
right it's not about algos it's about
putting it into practice okay great
you're a UC is where it is the AUC of a
slightly
first model is not that bad either the
problem is you struggle to get it into
production the problem is you have no
way to update things alright that's the
problem
so I finally learned because I'm not
that smart it the value of all analytics
is in production so we as analytics
people need to figure out a way to
actually put models into production and
so what I want to talk about today is
the way that we can combine resources to
put models into production alright so
show hands here how many data
engineering type people are there like
pipelining if I said data pipeline errs
how many of those people are there out
there ok and then how many pure
analytics people like they they use
random forests and gradient boosting
machines and deep learning and GPU stuff
and all that ok and then the remainder
maybe we're figuring it out ok so we're
going to talk about value the value of
analytics and production with the notion
and a lot of you sort of notice that its
production data science which is leading
disruption right you look at Airbnb and
face in in really Facebook the original
right but Airbnb and uber and mint calm
and learn best and you know I talked to
a guy from clue earlier today or
yesterday really it's taking data
science packaging it in a convenient way
putting it into production that's
actually causing disruption and the rest
of the world the non valley world is
straw still trying to catch up with that
right so you look at the big retailers
in Arkansas all right you talk about the
big insurance companies in the Midwest
they all want to get there they're not
quite there yet some of this talk is
aimed at the big companies right how
does the big company get there how do
they organize behavior alright and the
takeaway that I want to leave you with
is Voltron
does anybody remember Voltron that's it
I have to have more hands up for Voltron
Voltron is like the coolest cartoon
within the 80s I guess is 80s so who
knows volt we had like three hands for
Voltron
you know Voltron all right what was
Voltron yeah like yelled out all these
cats right and then they sort of like
glob together and to accomplish this
giant awesome butt kickin robot right
yes yes it was oh my god Voltron was
great right it's like transformers but
the Transformers collaborated alright
it's collaborative transformers so
here's my point there will never be
enough full stack data scientists ever
and I know here in the valley you're all
going shut up you know there's plenty of
full stack data scientists to go around
but let me tell you outside the valley
they're really hard to find well define
a full stack data scientists in a second
but it is hard to find full stack data
scientists so what are their
requirements we'll get into that how do
we have a what I think is a decently
unique way to deal with the shortage the
other focus is where do academia data
scientists come from what academic
divisions do they come from all right
and this is really important how many
computer science people are in here it
came from computer science okay for
people at home that's like a third how
about from Statistics proper a couple
Social Sciences that's like econ finance
stuff like that ah hard sciences
chemistry math stuff like that alright
so by far computer science
okay so we'll don't worry I'm guaranteed
to insult each and every one of you at
some point in this talk all right that's
sort of my goal if you don't insult one
person salt everybody at least once
you've you've failed miserably and then
we're going to talk to different
disciplines and then potentially talk
about how to build teams for different
purposes okay who is not seen this one
before this is the one of the Venn
diagrams talking about data science
right so in the data science world you
know you have you put together somebody
with hacking skills and math and
statistics skills and and substance
substantive expertise and and the the
intersection of all of these is what we
call like the data scientist and this
was the first attempt to categorize what
a data scientist was all right you know
it assumes homogeneity of skills in each
circle and that's probably just not
right you know not everyone with hacking
skills has the same hacking skills not
everyone with math and science skills
have the same math and science skills
not everyone with substantive expertise
is that has the same quality expertise
all right but if you have a little bit
of all those things you can call
yourself a data scientist some folks
even call themselves the data scientist
and they only have maybe one alright and
then someone came along and put it put
together a more complicated version and
broke it down by algorithms and somehow
found at the intersection of knowing all
these little different things made you a
data scientist a jack of all trades
master of none right that that that is
the next evolution of how to think about
a data scientist I propose something
completely different
instead I don't call people data
scientists I think they come from the
data Sciences okay there's no such thing
as a data scientist it doesn't exist I
know there are programs out there in
data science and there are programs out
there in analytics but even those
programs are bringing people from other
places there is no single set of skills
to be a data scientist you actually have
to have a bunch of different skills and
odds are your team has to have a bunch
of different skills because data science
is a team sport okay so let's talk about
the team sport the first of the data
scientists that I want to introduce is
the biostatistician any set
biostatisticians or statisticians in
here one that's it
statistics computational statistics
what's that
all right there you go perfect so you
will get to be the first person that I
insult all right so where do your data
come from and you know why is this
important because you need to think I
work for this I work for a certain kind
of company my company deals with these
kinds of data primarily right they also
need to solve these kinds of problems so
see this from the perspective of where
can I go out and find talent where
should I be recruiting because we're not
tell me your name in the back of the
room Alisa we're not all is lucky to
have Alyssa's self-identify sometimes we
have to go get them if you've ever
talked to any recruit who's actively
talked to a recruiter in the lately okay
it's a don't put your hands up - like
don't turn towards the camera right
because then your boss is going to know
what's going on but you know the issue
with a lot of recruiters right is they
they see the business application they
see that you've worked in an industry
they don't see X's and Y's and data
sciences see X's and Y's right we know
that the X's and Y's across all
industries are pretty much the same all
right it's it's really that you know
that that it's the interpretation right
that ends up being that ends up being
different so let's talk about what a
biostatistician is good at first of all
their data come from experimental lab
right I mean it's great we run we run
little trials we kill rats and right I
mean we put rats out there we'd give
them stuff and then they die so we're
really good at that so what kind of date
what kind of companies do do these like
get these kinds of data all right a lot
of market research type companies
obviously do run experimental type
design all right your favorite tool of
course is GLM all right I I was a social
scientist right so GLM is everyone know
GLM hands up if you don't it's okay all
right
short answer is it's a number roughly an
umbrella term which brings a little
bunch of regression concepts together
okay
so for the biostatistician they loved
GLM their strengths of course are in
experimental design what are their
weaknesses data created in the real
world now most companies data are
created in the real world so is a
biostatistician perhaps a great
forecaster maybe not all right so if I
need to build a team that is primarily
doing a/b testing okay maybe maybe there
a decent you maybe there a decent type
person for all these I'm going to my
most offensive thing is is of course
what picture comes to mind when I think
of a biostatistician it's a petri dish
all right so when I think of a
biostatistician this is what I think
about they they have experimental data
from the lab their favorite tools GLM
their strengths or experimental design
their struggles are with real-world data
at least out of the box
okay survey statisticians what are they
good at experimental and observational
data comes from the government the
current population survey American
Community Survey these are both you know
typical typical data sets what are their
favorite tools replicate weights
regression their strengths or survey
methodology ok great for market research
weaknesses they tend not to know a whole
lot about advanced predictive techniques
so they don't spend a lot of time with
lasso they don't spend a lot of time
with trees ok they don't spend a lot of
time with deep learning because their
goal is interpretation all right
so if you've got an interpretation need
look to survey statisticians they
actually know a lot ok and of course you
have census enumerator as your as your
picture all right now my favorite how
many from how many people come from the
finance econ social science background
it's going to be one or two in here
financier econ yeah or econ all right
same
yeah geografía litical science sociology
what'd you guys study alright so anyway
so here's this one's the most fun for me
because of course I'm making fun of
myself what are we good at secondary
data and observational data alright
so we're not we're not actively
collecting right we're sort of passively
collecting retail applications this is
perfect this is exactly what you get
okay
favorite tool of course is linear
regression really really good at OLS all
right
what's the problem or what what are they
also what do they understand the data
generating process so is this is this a
term this is probably a term that you
haven't heard a lot heard many times
before and oftentimes with predictive
modeling and machine learning you don't
really care okay but the data generating
process is how the observation was
created and so oftentimes failing to
acknowledge how data were created will
lead you to very poor results in
interpretation you know I was I was
quoted some sort of internet thing about
the the the sales of the Amazon Alexa
echo is it echo that was called Alexa
Amazon why am i spacing on this thing
it's a tube okay so so right up till
Christmas they were selling a whole lot
of them and then the handful of days
before Christmas the sales went to zero
all right and then they picked back up
in late December was the demand zero
during those days did they sell did they
sell zero they so they sold zero but the
zero didn't mean zero and that's
something that gets lost all the time
when you don't think about the data
generating process in fact it makes you
a bit of a skeptic about all data
analysis when you start looking at you
start looking at distributions right I
start thinking what does that mean what
it means
could the zero mean something else does
missing that is it is the right way to
capture this and is a missing value all
right we don't talk about missing values
a lot in
in machine learning all right maybe we
should
anyway statistician excuse me economists
spend a lot of time thinking about that
problem data quality problems what are
their weaknesses of course they have
very few techniques beyond linear
regression so they know OLS they just
don't know anything else okay and that's
not true of all economists we're getting
there
all right we're just a little slower to
the slower to the party what do I think
about with economist
does anybody know that this is I'm
getting to the point where nobody knows
who this is come on I had to have one in
here who how many Ghostbusters fans out
there are there Ghostbusters the
greatest movie ever all right one so
that's Rick Moranis right and actually
he played an accountant and Ghostbusters
but I realized that I probably wasn't
like right in the econ world when I went
to a conference and everybody looked
just like that all right
he just that's him all right so Rick
Moranis you know that's what I think of
when I think of economists we know OLS
we don't know much else
market research marketing science so
very quickly here the data are
observational and experimental the
favorite tool
conjoint marketing mix analysis
attribution analysis these are all very
very common things for for market
research the strengths they're very
applied they often know Bayesian
techniques the weaknesses they don't
have much time series experience and of
course you know something like that
right can I ask you a question so sir
market research market surveys that's
that's really what I what I think of
operations research operational and
passive or observational and passive
favorite tool is optimization all right
strengths optimization and forecasting
so they happen to know those things what
don't they know they have little
knowledge of the data generating process
every problem that they see is an
optimization problem again not bad but
for certain applications useful in
certain applications not what do I think
about I think about the Traveling
Salesman problem right what's the
optimal route to move people around
given the constraints that are faced
okay a couple more of these before I get
to the adulting most everybody in here
engineering and physics if you have
machine data people that come from an
engineering background or physics
background are particularly useful
they understand time-frequency analysis
they understand the jada generating
process of complex systems what's their
weakness they don't really understand
how humans make decisions okay they
understand how machines make decisions
they do a very poor job of how humans
make decisions all right and of course
you know I think about the time
dimension or how water flows through
tanks do you guys remember that I hated
that in school like that was maybe the
main reason why I disliked math until I
got older like I didn't like I liked the
dollar sign in front of stuff like it
was really boring if it was how fast is
the tank empty I didn't care okay ah now
the computer science is this is so much
fun right so I blew my animation so you
will see computer scientists data don't
care
favorite tool really doesn't matter I'm
just worried about validation sample
error statistics right so I'm just
worried just classic machine learning
type problems strengths you a understand
prediction they understand production
weaknesses they can't really talk about
why things happen all right
useful but maybe not what you need all
the time there are some problems where
prediction is the most important thing
and then in some cases it's not and of
course what do I think of I think of a
hoodie all right finally the data
scientists data I come from different
places and they're somewhat agnostic to
how it was created favorite tools they
know regression they know trees they
know clustering the strengths great at
data prep understand machine learning
weaknesses I would say if there's a
weakness its causality okay so when you
find a data scientist and you start
talking to a classic classically trained
that is they went through a master's
degree program in analytics which of now
there's
there's hundreds of all right they tend
to know a lot about a lot of a lot about
a good amount about a lot of things
right and then causalities is usually
the thing that I find that they struggle
with okay so for market research job
applications probably not so hot what
are they well they're hoodie wearers
except they they were Tyson okay so the
only difference existed okay so the only
difference between two computer
scientists in the analytics person is
they they dress it up a little bit they
dress it up right okay so what does a
full-stack data scientist know well they
know R or Python really really well it's
not okay to know SAS or Stata or MATLAB
or Eve use all right anyone know any of
those SAS data MATLAB eviews any hands
up for any of those all right MATLAB
ends up okay so mostly MATLAB of the
people that I just talked to now not
that again this is this is me
tongue-in-cheek MATLAB data scientists
are some of the smartest that I know
okay but to be considering yourself a
full stack data scientist you really
need to know R or Python and really are
doesn't count okay you need to know
Python alright you also need to know web
servers and web services you also need
to know spark Scala and be able to talk
about it you need to know Hadoop you
need to know Java you need to know d3
you need to know statistics and some
optimization and some forecasting and on
top of it you need to know business
problems like churn up cell fraud
inventory management predictive
maintenance product recommendations in
other words you got to know let's save
my pictures again
all those guys then they were supposed
to come in one by one right but you got
to know R and Python and and a web
server and Scala and docker and spark
and Hadoop any of you want all of those
things nobody of course not all right
but we keep advertising for the full
stack data scientists and we keep
thinking that we're going to be able to
find this person that knows everything
and in the real world that
doesn't exist okay so here's the
solution to the problem Voltron
okay the solution of the problem is
Voltron figure out a way as best as
possible to abstract away from the
technology so this is you're setting up
a team understand that it's going to be
impossible to find one person that
satisfies all the needs instead you're
going to have to build a collaborative
team you abstract away from the
technology you have to think of think
about piecing together teams what type
of problem am I trying to solve where
can I go and find that person that can
solve that little part of the problem
instead of thinking about I need to find
one person that can solve the entire
problem if companies especially big
companies and I didn't ask this but is
anyone here work for a publicly traded
company big biggish okay so you know how
do I solve this problem if I'm a big
company I figure out ways to pull little
pieces together
all right I've Voltron it ah and I do
that with a with maybe a software
platform that encourages vertical
collaboration so what do I mean on the
Left I have a data team right and this
data team is composed of bunch of data
engineers a bunch of data analysts a
bunch of data scientists and some lines
of business managers all right so big
companies have teams like this there are
software out there that supports
collaboration with these people all
right and I like a lot of that software
alright that software helps typically in
this dimension
it helps horizontally all right meaning
I can see what other people are doing
but I I can only understand it if I'm
like them all right and so data sight
data analysts can work too
other the data scientist can potentially
work together that the horizontal
collaboration lets substitutable
products substitutable resources work
together what I'm interested in trying
to promote is not necessarily the
horizontal collaboration concept but
instead this notion of vertical
collaboration all right so figure out a
platform figure out a group of people
that when they when they work together
in a in a vertical way can be Voltron
all right
figure out a way that if I'm going to
build a data product or an analytic
service how can I grab different kinds
of folks abstract away from technology
line them up so with it when I put them
together I have a kick-ass robot okay
that's that's my that's I think the
vision for where our industry is going
to go all right and it's also going to
let us ascend into higher levels of
Management all right we have to figure
out a way to get up up the ladder like
I'm tired of the NBA's okay
I'm tired of the NBA's always being the
boss we should be the boss okay so we
can only be the boss if we if we figure
out somebody else that can do our job a
vertical collaboration can help that all
right
horizontal is important is to of course
but but vertical is important all right
so that was the that was the totally
agnostic non data I to part of this talk
and then I'm going to spend like two
minutes I promise just giving like a
tiny little pitch for data IQ since
we're a sponsor and I flew all the way
out here so I figure I I can do it so
you can cut the video at this point if
you want but now the punchline of course
is that's a little bit what data Akoo
does okay
so data or data science studio is a
platform for vertical collaboration all
right all the stuff that I mentioned
before
Scala or spark are Python ml live h2o
all that stuff's in the box
okay but what we try to do is abstract
away from technology and give there an
opportunity for both types of users to
touch the software at the same time okay
in essence we're a conductor of other
technologies we try to piece all we try
to use the best of the algo world best
of the data world right so we conduct to
do we conduct spark we conduct our we
conduct Python we conduct web services
that kind of stuff and we throw it or
gather in a seamless environment where
you can build data products and analytic
services all right so that is the
official end of my talk and I'd love
that opportunity for some Q&A if if
you're interested in and maybe asking
about what I see as far as trends in
data science throughout most of the
country I have the benefit actually of
visiting so it's a sigh visited hundreds
of sites and it might last two companies
I get to visit sites all the time so I
see what's happening in like the non
valley part of the world
so with that maybe a question or two all
right
thanks Kim yeah thank you so we have
time for a couple of questions and then
Ken will also be available upstairs
there you go where as office hours so
it's got to be something out there yes
good
okay so everybody so what is happening
in the nan Valley part of the world a
lot let me give you one example so four
years ago I went to a big retailer in
Northwest Arkansas with an with an out
with a with a big statistics company and
I walk through that that part of the
world and the offices look like one of
their large retail establishments low
ceilings drop ceilings fluorescent
lights joint tables not good a year ago
I went back to that exact same building
the ceilings had been ripped out new
lighting was in place I don't know if it
had any windows or not I don't think it
was possible to put windows in but it
was virtually indistinguishable from one
of the you know where was like
Facebook's office in fact it's nicer
than Facebook's office so what's
happening in the rest of the world
they're catching up it's taking them a
while but they're understanding that
they need to transition into us being a
software company that's true at big
credit company in in Virginia same thing
right you walk in it looks like a
software company it feels like a
software company they they're still
lacking the the Institute they like top
to bottom institutional adoption of of
analytics semi but but it's getting
there all right but you know I still
talk to companies all the time that are
sort of embarrassed that they don't have
their Hadoop strategy worked out right
where we all have kind of just said you
know Hadoop sold so let's just worry
about spark and forget that you know
it's cool it's a good storage just you
know it's great for storage
you know thank God I have a big
supercomputer now that's basically what
we think of Hadoop right you guys ever
thought about that like why did it take
so like why did it take so long for
companies to get these big
supercomputers well nobody figured out
that they could just you know that's the
real benefit of what the Hadoop cluster
was was that it gave us supercomputing
alright uh anybody else there's got to
be another question out there what
industry do I think is touching data
science bringing data science and Oh an
actual question yeah and what I find is
that oftentimes the challenge is more
than the tools it's the fact that
because of the different backgrounds we
speak very different languages the way
we frame problems about what is
important what is a reasonable
assumption and what is a reasonable
objective is different and so it's more
of a cultural speaking the same language
and then a tool is yeah so there is a
there there is thank you so there is a
you know tools are one part of the issue
the other part of the issue is
understanding where people come from and
creating a common language you know part
of the common language is of course
comes from continual learning
interacting with people not something
that our group that it's mate is natural
to us we're not terribly social people
right but finding I mean it's true right
even I wasn't always like this I just I
got lucky I was dropped into SAS right
and so it at SAS I I was an economist in
a land of statisticians and optimization
people and biostatisticians and market
research folks and GIS people and
and I got lucky enough to just bounce
around and get their language but for
the most part everybody has the same
fundamentals in that they understand
regression and so start from there all
right start from a start but but
understand also that what is the
objective of this particular subgroup
they are coming to it from an
optimization perspective so whatever
regression concept that I think about
their goal is to you know find the best
outcome then there's the market research
person their goal is always going to be
explanation there's the the you know the
math person I wish as a preference for
elegans there's there's always going to
be some sort of differences among us you
know commonality is kind of the finding
a simple simple somewhat simple
commonality of course is how you start
you know I'd say short of experience in
time I'm trying to think if there was
any other what else helped
I'd say at knowing that you don't know
everything being humble enough to ask
like what do you what do you mean so I
did a I did a talk with a podcast with a
gentleman I told you a little bit ago
but we were talking about Kafka
I don't know squat about Kafka I'm still
trying to understand it right but but I
think asking enough questions gets me
closer so we have to be ok with I like
being the dumbest guy in the room it's
fun I'd always rather be the dumbest guy
in the room life gets miserable when
you're the smartest person in the room
so maybe that's the answer put yourself
in a room with people smarter than you
ok